mais d'abord les résultats officiels de
premier tour de cette présidentielle
2022 il faut aussi les avoir bien en
tête emmanuel macron devant avec 27 8%
des suffrages exprimés devant la
candidate du rassemblement national 23,1
jean luc mélenchon est à 22 ça
représente très exactement 421 milles
420 voix d'écart avec marine le pen
ensuite vous le voyez c'est vertigineux
eric zemmour 7,1 valérie pécresse 4,8
yannick jadot à
4,6 et puis on trouve ensuite jean
lassalle fabien roussel nicolas dupont
aignan anne hidalgo
1,8 pour cent seul philippe poutou et
nathalie arthaud font moins bien
bonsoir à tous mes invités bérengère
bonté bienvenue journaliste essayiste
auteur de le sioux portrait des leurs
philippe aux éditions de l'archipel
falek potier bonsoir du co directeur de
l'observatoire des radicalités politique
à la fondation jean jaurès jean daniel
lévy bonsoir soit bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes directeur délégué d'harris
interactive france et matthieu
croissandeau éditorialiste politique
bonsoir bonsoir de mathieu route vous
retrouvez comme tous les lundis et
mercredis jean daniel lévy au delà des
chiffres bruts il ya des disparités qui
sont intéressantes à analyser dans l'est
selon les régions la taille des villes à
votre mélenchon dans les grandes villes
à votre mac rond à l'ouest ça bref il ya
comme ça des lignes de fracture
intéressante oui des lignes de fracture
très intéressantes des lignes de
fracture qui peut être aussi bien un
géographe et que vous en avez donné
quelques éléments mais également à
caractère social ou générationnel un des
enseignements majeurs qu'on va tirer
c'est la captation de l'électorat âgé de
la part d' emmanuel macron on sait que
2010 est il lève un électorat qui était
assez et alain vous regardiez quasiment
dans toutes les catégories de population
il arrivait à réunir à peu de choses
près entre 23 et 25 % des différentes
générations là il a vraiment réussi à
récupérer l'électorat qui est âgé de 50
ans et plus et même 65 ans et plus et on
sait que historiquement c'était plutôt
en tout cas en 2010 est la force de
françois fillon dont il ya eu cette
bascule qui bascule à caractère
politique
la bascule à caractère générationnel et
puis et de la bascule à caractère
géographique est tel qu'on a pu
l'identifier c'est un des points tout
cas qui nous a le plus marqué et qui
vient confirmer des tendances qu'on
avait commencé à entrevoir dès les
élections législatives qui ont été
confirmés aux élections européennes et
qui trouve quelque peu leur
aboutissement hier bérengère bonté votre
analyse de la première place d'emmanuel
macron il est fait presque 4 points de
mieux qu'en 2017 est ce que c'est un
vrai succès ou une première place en
trompe l'oeil
c'est une première place on m'a pas le
lui enlever effectivement c'est une
première place qui ensuite va de va
nécessiter d'être d'être abondée on va
dire parler des reports de voix qui sont
kiss kiss à huy qui on en parlera sans
doute qu'ils existent mais qui sont
qui sont un peu compliquée dans la
mesure où d'ascq un peu hétérogène parce
qu'un peu hétérogène et puis parce que
peut-être en partie parce que on compte
en décrypte un peu le vote d'hier on
s'aperçoit que finalement le lectorat l
air qui était un qui était un vrai
une vraie réserve en 2017 et déjà
aujourd'hui l'électorat de d'emmanuel
macro et socialement en termes de
revenus etc on s'aperçoit que
visiblement on est déjà avec nous alors
c'est petit c'est l'électorat des rixes
et moi
c'est évidemment un volume moins
important donc c'est c'est
incontestablement une première place on
a même
certains ont dit dans les derniers jours
quelconque que les deux que les deux
corps allait se rapprocher ce n'est
marine le pen est celui des manières
matran ce qui n'a pas été le cas donc
oui c'est une c'est une première place
on ne peut pas non plus frites petit le
premier parti de france il faut le
rappeler sont d'avoir les
abstentionnistes c'est important parce
qu'on l'a on attend ça oubliez ce
chiffre là et après c'est le vote
protestataire oui on a deux
personnalités politiques qui ont capté
cette france des colères marine le pen
évidemment cave en deuxième position qui
augmente par rapport à 2007 et jean luc
mélenchon qui l'oxi augment d'un petit
peu par rapport à 2017 mais à la
différence c'est que il les puise
complètement les voix de gauche chez les
autres candidatures et donc on se
retrouve dans une forme de triangulation
de tri partisane isation je sais pas
quand il faut le dire de la vie
politique française avec un clivage que
le président est pudique cherche à
favoriser à instaurer d'un côté les
progressistes les libéraux les pro
européens puis de l'autre côté ce qui
serait une nationaliste partisan d'un
repli identitaire ou d'un repli tout
court sur le plan des relations
internationales mathieu si on se penche
sur la la le score de jean luc mélenchon
il échoue une nouvelle fois aux portes
du second tour je le disais dans les
titres ses 420 mille voix et quelques
mais pour certains cette descente avait
des allures de victoire oui nous
surprendra toujours jean luc mélenchon
ils ont en en rail est ici sur ce
plateau parfois sa campagne en trouvant
un petit un petit air de déjà vu eh ben
il a fini
il a fait différemment il faut le dire
il a fini de façon très différente hier
soir et de quelle façon a d'abord le
score on en a parlé évidemment 21 et le
95 % 22 pour arrondir troisième force
politique du paysage un poil de fès
comme dirait adrien catane 1 son
lieutenant je ne serais pas permis sinon
à un poil de fès disais-je de la
qualification pour le second tour mais
loin très loin devant tous les autres
puis on à 17,7 millions de voix 700
milles de plus qu'en 2010 est dans un
pays qu'on disait droitiser voire
extrême droitisée il a quand même relevé
le drapeau de la gauche il a fait
différemment ensuite dans l'attitude
hier soir malgré la défaite et belle
tribun a conservé sa verve mais a
remplacé l'agressivité par l'humour ce
qui était quand même pas évident on le
sortait libéré en fête en cette fin de
campagne moi j'ai vu il ya quelques
jours avant vendredi dernier près s'il
était au comptant est conscient d'avoir
fait le job en fait dans sa tête et de
sortir de la course présidentielle la
tête haute hier soir il a été d'une
certaine façon de meilleur perdant il a
donc pas tourné autour du pot il a joué
la carte de la clarté quelle quelle
différence par rapport à 2007 où il
avait commencé par un peu contesté les
résultats puis par pas dire pour qui ils
voulaient voter hier on a vu vraiment un
autre jean luc mélenchon quand même
entame une forme de passage de témoin
mais qu'est ce qu'il va faire maintenant
alors sur un plan personnel il n'a pas
encore annoncé de façon claire s'il se
retirer ou non
de la vie politique et législative reste
évidemment un point d'interrogation mais
à 70 ans et plus de cinq décennies de
militantisme derrière lui l leader
insoumis tient là une occasion en or
s'il le souhaitait évidemment de prendre
un peu de recul ou en tout cas de ne
plus jouer les premiers rôles ses amis
le disent fatigué mais pas usé il est à
la fois trop jeune et encore trop actif
pour se contenter ou se satisfaire de
jouer les vieux sages mais il est quand
même trop âgées sans doute pour
envisager une nouvelle aventure de
premier plan alors sur le plan politique
quel que soit son choix il a plusieurs
choses à faire d'abord il a encore du
pain sur la planche à gauche a dit en
général et à commencer par les insoumis
pas ce qu'il va voir qui prépare sa
succession en bonne et due forme ce qui
est pas une mince affaire quand on
connaît un peu ce mouvement gazeuse rae
la foire qu'il soit deviennent un peu
plus solide
jean luc mélenchon n'est pas remplaçable
a dit ce matin toujours adrien cat and
haas mais en tout cas son mouvement a
besoin de structures qui permettent à la
fois de plus démocratie plus de
délibérations s'il veut s'inscrire dans
la durée ensuite ça va venir très vite
très vite il va falloir transformer
l'essai de la présidentielle en
reconstruction de la gauche et alors là
le leader insoumis comme son vieil
adversaire françois hollande il
considère que c'est pas à l'union qui
fait la force mais que c'est la force
qui fait l'union et pour le coup c'est
incontestable a forcé les aujourd'hui à
gauche chez jean luc mélenchon se
projette vers les législatives et ça
pourrait donner quoi il y aura des
accords ou non
avec les verts ou pas avec le ski reste
du ps ça aurait peut-être pas le coup
est ce qu'il va se rabibocher avec le
communiste quelles initiatives qui peut
prendre pour reconstruire la gauche il
n'a pas le goût des discussions
d'appareils un jean luc mélenchon on le
sait ils appellent ça la tambouille la
soupe au logo mais en face il veut
inscrire son nom dans l'histoire de la
gauche autrement que pour ses belles
campagnes présidentielles il va falloir
qu'ils s'y attellent car la demande
existe on a encore vu hier soir jean
daniel en parler dans la jeunesse dans
les grandes villes en ile-de-france dans
les outre-mer on a vu des électeurs
convaincus ou orphelins votants utile ou
efficace on peut appeler ça comme on
veut mais en tout cas qui d appeler une
forme de sursaut en 2017 jean luc
mélenchon avait choisi de faire cavalier
seul vous soutenez vous souvenez son
entrée à l'assemblée nationale à la tête
d'un petit groupe s'était fait de façon
aussi brillante qu'un puissante parce
qu'au fond ça n'a rien donné pendant ce
quinquennat à part protesté l'assemblée
nationale il avait même fait dans la rue
en solo plutôt que de jouer avec les
syndicats en 2022 le voilà aujourd'hui
libéré une partie de ses ambitions et
jean luc mélenchon n'a plus rien à
prouver à personne sauf à lui-même qu'il
est capable de passer du rôle de tribun
talentueux de tous les mains de la plèbe
à celui de grands architectes et ça
c'est tout suivant une autre question ça
fait partie des enjeux des prochains
jours des plantes et des prochains mois
pour jean luc mélenchon reviendra sur
ces questions de reports de voix je vous
propose de répondre à une première
question en images sur une hypothèse de
victoire de marine le pen peut-elle
l'emporter dans 13 jours il ya cinq ans
c'était une hypothèse peu vraisemblable
c'est aujourd'hui une probabilité
réaliste pierre-henri holder barn
la fiche du second tour entre emmanuel
macron et marine le pen est plus serré
qu'en 2017 selon notre sondage ipsos
sopra steria le président recueillerait
54% des voix contre 46 pour la candidate
du rassemblement national alors les
prétendants sont à la pêche aux
électeurs si valérie pécresse a appelé à
voter emmanuel macron la réserve de voix
des républicains restent faibles dans la
dernière intentions de vote qu'on a
réalisé pour le second tour
45% des électeurs de valérie pécresse
pense voter pour emmanuel macron donc
c'est quand même moins d'un sur deux et
le reste se répartit alors là tu % pour
marine le pen 27% par l'abstention de
son côté marine le pen pourra compter
sur les électeurs d'eric zemmour mais là
aussi la réserve de voix restent aussi
faible pour talonner emmanuel macron
alors les candidats ciblés lectorat de
jean luc mélenchon qui a obtenu 21,9
pour cent des votes c'est en tout cas le
le report le plus volatile c'est à dire
celui qui a les plus indécis du rapport
un tiers un tiers un tiers c'est à dire
à peu près un petit peu plus d'un tiers
qui se reporteraient sur emmanuel macron
à peu près aussi un petit peu plus d'un
tiers sur marine le pen et environ un
tiers qu'ils s'abstiendraient à
l'annoncé des résultats la candidate du
rassemblement national s'est adressé à
l'électorat de gauche qu'on voit bien
que sa stratégie va être vraiment visez
l'électorat de gauche l'électorat
populaire de gauche de toute façon c'est
la stratégie qu'elle a décidé de mettre
en place depuis le premier tour s'est
parlé du pouvoir d'achat elle a laissé
eric zemmour les thèmes identitaires et
donc là je pense qu'elle va insister
encore plus sur cette thématique là avec
les mesures sur le rsa sur les
enseignants et sur les retraites
emmanuel macron va jouer à
l'équilibriste d'abord un élément de
forme qui est de peut-être remettre en
discussion
une partie effectivement des mesures
voilà qui suscite en tout cas le plus de
défiance aujourd'hui dans un électorat
comme celui du pôle enfant par exemple
ça un élément évidemment important de
son antre de tours et avec un autre
élément qui pour lui stratégiquement est
important qui est d'élargir aussi son
programme et d'enrichir son programme à
d'autres sujets il ya des propositions à
amender d'une part et des propositions
qui pourraient venir les garnir
finalement et son programme notamment
autour des questions écologiques et
environnementales au lendemain du
premier tour emmanuel macron s'est rendu
dans le nord où marine le pen a réalisé
ses meilleurs scores et compte
intensifier ses déplacements
alors je vous redonne notre projection
partenaires ipsos sopra steria notre
partenaire des soirées présidentielle 1
54 46 en faveur d' emmanuel macron
jean-daniel votre dernier baromètre
harris interactive vous êtes alors et
dans ces eaux là ça ça compte 3 47 tu es
un candidat très grande proximité fait
47 alors où sont les réserves de voix le
président par intérim du rnd jordan
bardella à sa réponse
le bloc national que nous représentons
que nous portons les mondialistes qui
sont représentés par emmanuel macron qui
veulent encore plus de dérégulation et
puis évidemment le blog de jean luc
mélenchon donc
si vous voulez on me pose la question
depuis hier où sont vos réserves devant
terry c'est une vraie question
chez pécresse et 70% de france emmanuel
macron parce que c'est un échec pour lui
en vérité 70% des français qui votent
contre emmanuel macron c'est 70% des
français qui savent que si emmanuel
macron est réélu ça va être cinq années
supplémentaires de casse sociale
jean daniel lévy est ce que c'est aussi
simple que ça ce que réserve de voix de
le pen sans chez 70% de français
mécontents ou en colère contre le
président sortant n'est si c'était aussi
simple que ça probablement que marine le
pen aurait réalisé un meilleur score
hier même si est la risée déjà un score
qui est historiquement élevé et je crois
pour l'apa beaucoup souligné mais c'est
le score qui n'a jamais été relevée pour
une candidate ou un candidat du front
national nous rassure nationale + 23 %
c'est loin d'être négligeable d'autant
plus qu'il y avait eric zemmour donc
c'est pas forcément cette situation qui
existe pour nous à nos yeux un des
principal enjeu ce avec l'enjeu de la
participation électorale on a vu par
exemple en 2017 au cours de la dernière
élection que il y avait une croissance
forte pour la première fois de
l'abstention entre le premier tour il
deuxième tour en général on voit de plus
au deuxième tour de l'élection
présentielle y avait une exception
c'était 1969 losc avait eu la
confrontation de deux candidats de
droite mais ça ne s'est pas produit au
cours de la dernière récession ou 25 %
d'abstention au deuxième tour et puis
surtout 4 millions de personnes qui ont
pris un bulletin blanc ou nul ça veut
dire que sur 100 personnes qui se
rendent dans un bureau de vote vous en
avez 12 qui ont refusé de choisir entre
marine le pen à l'époque et emmanuel
macron en 2010 est donc ça sera un des
principal enjeu va-t-il y avoir ou pas
une transformation de la mobilisation
non seulement pour marine le pen mais
encore plus pour emmanuel macron pour
éviter qu'il puisse y avoir
effectivement cette frange de population
qui est critique qui basculerait donc
non pas dans un référendum pour ou
contre le racisme nationale comme cflhta
le cas pendant longtemps mais à un
référendum pour ou contre et emmanuel
macron effectivement est-ce que frey
potier le le front républicain avec une
définitivement emmanuel macron en
déplacement dans le nord aujourd'hui le
disais à l'évidence en tout cas il a
moins de force qu'auparavant et il sait
plus réflexe ça c'est clair néanmoins on
a pu entendre quand même hier soir
dimanche soir des l'annoncent destin des
résultats un certain nombre de consignes
de vote très clair à gauche chez jadot
chicago chez roussel et même jean luc
mélenchon a été beaucoup plus clair dans
son propos qu'ils ne l'étaient il ya
cinq ans dans 10 ans 4 x 4 x 4 fois on
ne vote pas marine le pen pas une voix
pour mary bale une voie pour marine le
pen madame le pet et donc d'être l'enjeu
qui aura c'est effectivement celui-là
est ce que l'électorat mélenchonistes se
réfugiera dans l'abstention est ce qu'il
ira voter
pour emmanuel macron il ya là un enjeu
pour le président sortant les blancs
mais pour marine le pen ya à peu près la
même question puisque d'un côté il lui
faut aller récupérer sa réserve de voix
quasi naturel chez eric zemmour et en
temps il faut qu'elle s'adresse à un
électorat plus populaire plus de gauche
avec certains éléments de son programme
même si ce programme est très aseptisé
et très on va dire enrobé de propos on
va dire très très soft il ya quand même
des points durs sur l'immigration la
sécurité les prestations sociales ouais
ben angers remonte on
on attend la confirmation d'une
éventuelle visite d' emmanuel macron au
havre jeudi ce jeudi je sais pas si vous
en avez vous vous avez des infos
puisqu'on connaissait bien il forcément
la ville du havre et l'entourage edouard
philippe pour avoir écrit un livre soit
il semblerait que ce soit confirmé ça
veut dire qu emmanuel macron ça
évidemment la science politique
n'échappe à personne a besoin d' edouard
philippe mais c'est ça reste à ce jour
deux ans après son départ de matignon la
personnalité politique préférée des
français tout le monde aura noté au
pratiquement sauf lui parce qu'il
prétend qu'il a été très présent mais
sans sa quasi absence du promu de la
compagne du premier tour il a fait un
meeting à nice
avec christian estrosi s'est à peu près
l'endroit le plus visible de cette
campagne et tout et
c'est un personnage qui enfin c'est pas
très étonnant quand on connaît
personnage moi je les ai vus comme ça a
avancé dans cette campagne chaque fois
qu'ils avaient l'occasion de dire qu'il
était loyal il le disait mais sans en
faire trop et comme s'ils se réservait
pour s'étendre de tours pour cette
espèce de deus ex machina le moment où
il est celui qui va planter la
banderille salvatrice et le moment fort
qui serait un meeting noir et je sais à
peu près comme ça que c'est en train de
se dérouler donc c'est pas tellement
étonnant du personnage je pense que les
macro ni seront contents de voir kylie
qu'il apporte sa pierre qui rentre dans
le jeu jean daniel lévy votre votre
dernier baromètre alors il est
passionnant sur les possibilités de
report notamment de l'électorat de jean
luc mélenchon alors dans le reportage
sera diffusé tout à l'heure on était sur
un tiers un tiers un tiers un tiers pour
et macro un tiers pour marine le pen à
un tiers de l'abstention c'est pas
exactement vos chiffres c'est pas
exactement les chiffres on a une forme
de stabilité par rapport aux enquêtes
qu'on a pu être amené à réaliser on peut
déjà dire que il ya un peu plus d'espacé
avec et créé après le premier tour la
présidentielle plus avant on allait
mesurer 51 5% pour être précis en faveur
d' emmanuel macron en fin de semaine
dernière on est à 53 pour cent cette
semaine donc une petite une petite
évolution quoi qu'il en soit l'électorat
de jean luc mélenchon où il penche déjà
en premier lieu vers l'abstention est
pour près d'une personne sur deux que
nous avons été amenés à interroger et
puis on a un tiers qui déclarent qu'ils
voteraient en faveur d' emmanuel macron
et 20% et qui utiliserait un bulletin de
vote marine le pen il ya des arts cela
deux dimensions je crois intéressante le
premier aspect c'est que marine le pen
fait quand même beaucoup moins peur à
cet électorat là même à cet électorat là
et quand on les interroge en fait sur
les conséquences que pourrait être
l'arrivée de marine le pen
l'idée fait d'avoir une remise en cause
de notre principe démocratique et nos
libertés fondamentales c'est
complètement annulé et puis en parallèle
et il y a un côté repoussoir pad
emmanuel macron autour d'un point de vue
général de ce qu'on appelle la question
sociale et qui est incarnée à travers
trois dimensions récente 1 la retraite à
65 ans 2 le rsa est en fait la
conditionnalité du versement du rsa à
une activité et puis 3 le rapport aux
enseignants et le fait que les
enseignants soient amenés à pouvoir être
mieux rémunérés si jamais et il devait
entre guillemets le mériter et on sait
que l'électorat jean luc mélenchon est
vraiment très sensible notamment sur cet
aspect là mathieu cécé de cette première
journée de campagne là on a commencé à
s'y intéresser dans ce dans ce premier
débat était intéressante et emmanuel
macron il ya cinq ans si je me souviens
bien il avait mis un petit retard à
l'allumage un peu
c'est pas faux sur deux premiers tours
et les perspectives de dépenses et la
rotonde et ben voilà il avait pas eu
vent du déplacement des rafales à hilla
il a attaqué bille en tête mais il
attaque bille en tête parce que ça au
fond tout ce qui n'a pas fait pendant
cette curieuse campagne avant le premier
tour c'est vrai que là il est en
déplacement dans le nord sur des terres
qui sont historiquement frontiste est
devenu ensuite des terres du
rassemblement national demain il sera en
alsace donc peut-être à war ensuite et
puis peut-être un meeting à marseille le
week-end prochain on voit bien qu'il va
faire en une semaine ce qu'il n'a pas
fait en il s'était déclaré le 3 mars ce
qu'il n'a pas fait en un peu plus d'un
mois alors je pensais qu'il a été pris
par par la guerre en ukraine bien sûr
mais il a donné ce sentiment de survoler
la campagne ce qui n'était pas bon pour
lui au fond parce qu'il est plutôt bon
quand il va au contact des français il
est plutôt bon dans le débat et et là ça
n'a fait que renforcer son image
d'isolement qu'est-ce qu'on a un
président candidat qui est coupé des
français son image d' arrogance je suis
un peu au dessus de la mêlée après vous
pourrez dire que c'est la dramatisation
de l'enjeu avec le resserrement prévu d
une gourde qui qu'on a qu'on a connu
à la fin de la semaine dernière à jouer
en fait dans sa faveur parce que ça peut
être trop mobiliser son électorat mais
vrai il ya quand même le sentiment y
compris dans la république en marchant
pas dans ses plus proches mais danger
des députés vous interrogez de la
campagne a été fait un peu sans queue ni
tête ou en tout cas en dépit du bon sens
et que là il faut ratisser parce que là
il faut qu'il aille chercher les voix
une par une il ya plus de réflexes
automatiques c'est vrai il ya une
jeunesse qui s'est détourné de lui c'est
quand même paradoxal on a le président
le plus jeune qui fait un carton chez
les plus âgés est le candidat le plus
âgé il fait un carton chez les jeunes a
quand même jean luc mélenchon avait
encaissé on est quand même dans un peu
cul par dessus tête et alors là en plus
comme il a mené une politique qui était
quand même de centre-droit avoir de
droite depuis cinq ans qu'il a plutôt
donné très très peu de gages à la gauche
là où quinze jours il va devoir
recentrer redevenir le et en même temps
à marcher sur ses deux jambes c'est
quand même assez compliqué et c'est pour
ça qu'il va se démultiplier et c'est une
nouvelle campagne qui commence a dit
gabriela talent ce matin c'était sur
france inter en écoute alors qu'on a eu
cinq ans de crise qu'on a traversé des
crises majeures la crise des gilet jaune
qui venaient de loin crise du coc gide
la guerre en ukraine emmanuel macron est
nettement en tête de ce premier tour et
améliore nettement son score par rapport
au premier tour de 2010 est donc
gratitude pour ceux qui ont voté devant
nous que je remercie évidemment j'ai
milité aussi parce que cette élection il
va falloir aller la chercher parce que
rien n'est joué
on sait qu'on va devoir soulagement
vaincre des français qui n'ont pas voté
pour emmanuel macron au premier tour qui
parfois ne partage pas du tout notre
projet mais ça va être l'enjeu de cet
entre deux toits et puis hier soir on a
vu passer un ovni au dessus de nos têtes
un objet politique non identifié ce
grand mouvement politique d'unité et
d'action que les hanter manuel macron a
parlé dans son premier discours
bérengère bon ça pourrait prendre quelle
forme je pense que tout le monde s'est
posé la question aujourd'hui est
personne vraiment trouvé de réponse même
au sein de deux équipes oui oui je sais
tu avoues la patate chaude mes camarades
mais
espèce de réflexe d'unité auquel en
général on ne pense pas avant le scrutin
et auquel on pense en particulier la
dans les quinze derniers jours alors on
va y mettre
d'un peu d'écologie soudain ce qui est
d'ailleurs assez paradoxal quand on voit
qu'il ya nick shadow fait même pas 5%
après tout les deux candidats marine le
pen comme comme emmanuel macron sont là
essayer de rajouter une écolo mais parce
qu'il ya pas mal de deux personnages de
faire 2 2 on est fatigués hollande
notamment l'avis de la population jeune
sur ces thématiques à voter jean luc
mélenchon donc le voilà ce que voulait
dire c'est que l'électorat écolo il est
plein il est peut-être en train
d'essayer d'aller chercher chez jean luc
mélenchon arrive enfin c'est cette
histoire d'aider des rectorats écolo et
des deux générations climat comme on l'a
dit est très intéressant d'ailleurs
observé j'ai ressenti le franchement
puisqu'on encore en matière de souligner
les plus jeunes sont allés voter
mélenchon même les plus jeunes sont
allés voter marine le pen dans des
proportions beaucoup plus importante que
ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on pensait donc en
tout cas ce rassemblement effectivement
il est destiné à essayer de rassembler
ce qui peut de d'essayer de d'achever ce
qui reste de deux des leurs après tout
là pour le coup le travail déjà est déjà
pas mal commencé et cyclos se passe et
faire des potiers ce grand mouvement
politique d'unité et d'action je suis
prêt à compléter mon projet notamment
sur l'écologie effectivement c'est ce
qu'a dit emmanuel mathieu manama crans à
a2 à tout à l'heure mais je crois que ce
grand mouvement politique il a soutenu
notre vocation c'est d'être prêt pour
les élections législatives hélas
aujourd'hui on a une majorité
présidentielle qui un peu et demi était
entre horizon l'helgouac'h d'edouard
philippe l'ailé gauche avec territoire
de progrès les progressistes avec le
maire de dijon françois rebsamen et
demain et bien la majorité
présidentielle devra investir 577
candidats et papus et donc je pense que
cet objet politique non identifié il a
une vocation très précis c'est ça c'est
se préparer aussi aux élections qui
auront lieu en juin on n'a jamais eu un
tel pas une telle évolution des
structures qui soutenait un candidat ou
un président de répliques un point on a
quand même eu en marche qui a été
constituée pour la conquête du pouvoir
puis la république en marche pour
l'exercice du pouvoir puis ensemble
citoyen qui a plus ou moins bon bien
fonctionné mais qui s'est constituée
justement pour la conquête et puis
effectivement cet ovni comme vous dites
et qu'un train de se faire et donc qu'on
est vraiment enfin j'veux pas dire dans
la start up née chaîne va chaque fois
c'est la constitution d'un objet
politique par objectifs et une fois que
l'objectif est atteint eh ben ils
changent de deux modalités de
fonctionnement ou au moins de nom alors
trop gêné au tour de la présidentielle
en général les vraies fausses et c'est
particulièrement forte de classer ces
singuliers ce qu'en général les
formations politiques qui changent
change quand elles sont en crise
quand elles sont en grande difficulté et
non pas lorsqu'elles ont atteint une
partie leurs objectifs mathieu oui c'est
de la stratégie électorale
c'est ce que un juppé appelé l'omelette
avec les deux bouts qui fait des dessins
sur le côté ça c'est l'idée c'est moi ou
le chaos donc le bras je suis le camp
des progressistes des européens des gens
sympas des gens cool et les autres sont
des affreuses extrémistes nationalistes
repliés sur eux mêmes c'est ça c'est ça
qui essaient d'imposer y compris dans
les idées madonna cran après ce quelle
forme ça prendra ça peut pas prendre une
forme dans dans l'entre-deux tours et
justine quand même une chose étonnante
c'est que les trois personnalités qui
sont en tête dans cette élection sont
toutes issues de partis qui ont très peu
d'implantation locale au fond soit parce
qu'elles ont fait l'impasse comme on dit
72 ont voulu en jambes et une
généralement parce que ce sont deux
bonnes années dans tous les scrutins
intermédiaires parce que elles ne savent
pas elles ne savent pas faire de la
politique sur le terrain au quotidien et
s'implanter localement doubs savez on va
en parler le leurre des partis
traditionnels
plr pas suffisamment travaillé continuer
de gagner c'est ça joue comme ça mais on
a quand même maintenant un vie politique
avec deux strates une strate de partis
autrefois protestataires mais qui
aujourd'hui ambitionne de devenir des
partis de gouvernement et qui sont des
partis sans vraiment de racines locales
rassemblement national n'y arrive pas la
france a soumises n'a quasiment aucun
élu n'a aucune ville et la république
est en marche a quand même eu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de mal aux scrutins
intermédiaires et puis une souce tracts
deux vieux partis qui qui gère des
collectivités locales est-ce que cela va
durer est ce que c'est bon pour notre
démocratie je m'en suis bien certain
c'est vrai aussi d'europe écologie
d'ailleurs d'une certaine façon un cas
qui a remporté plusieurs grandes villes
aux municipales et devient un parti de
gauche ajoutent une deuxième singularité
c'est qu' aucun des trois responsables
politiques est arrivé en tête hier n'est
tissu d'une primaire ou d'un processus
de désignation démocratique interne
c'est à dire qu'en fait il y avait il y
avait en fait en gros un chef entre
guillemets qui c'est qui s'est imposée
ou en tout cas une décision qui était
prisée tandis que les autres en fait ils
ont cherché d'une manière ou d'une autre
soient associés des citoyens soit faire
vivre un choeur militants se sont
retrouvés pour toutes à un niveau qui
était inférieur à 5% donc c'est à dire
au seuil de remboursement afrique petit
est ce que
notre démocratie a besoin d'être
réveillé à l'issue d'un tel scrutin on
attend les résultats du second tour
évidemment on verra bien ce qui se passe
mais les leçons qu'on doit tirer de ce
de ce premier tour est ce que ça oblige
pas le vainqueur que ce soit le
maquereau ou
marine le pen de réinsuffler du neuf
dans cette vème république déjà sur
l'abstention est dense que ça renvoie à
la participation électorale il ya quand
même trois quarts des français qui sont
allés voter c'est quand même plutôt un
signe encourageant là où on voyait la
crise la démocratie la défiance etc mais
en sens inverse on peut dire quelle a
été la motivation du vote et moi je
crois que dans la dernière ligne droite
les dernières 24 heures les dernières 72
heures il ya beaucoup de français qui
sont allés voter un peu par défaut un
peu par stratégie c'est vrai qu'elle
cette expression dans le monde je crois
des lecteurs machiavel avec des
électeurs qui se disait qu'il fallait
voter par exemple pour mélenchon pour
que marine le pen ne soit pas au second
tour mais pour permettre à maquereau
d'être élu donc on est vraiment des
calculs extrêmement compliqué et avec
une désaffiliation partisane très
prononcé certes les familles politiques
n'existent plus complètement ou presque
plus du tout on peut voter un jours à
droite le lendemain pour ussel et aux
élections locales c'est effectivement
complètement déconnecté de sa c'est à
dire que hidalgo quoi madame hidalgo
fait 2% à paris et yannick jadot fait 8
% à grenoble donc il ya cette
articulation qui est aussi compliquée
entre la démocratie au niveau national
11 i il ya un homme il faut voter pour
un homme ou une femme est un leader pour
cinq ans et de l'autre côté il ya des
pratiques de démocratie locale qui
peuvent être très poussées mais qui
obéissent à des logiques complètement
différent on y reviendra anne hidalgo
c'est 23 mille électeurs parisiens sur
un million de votants il c'est le
premier l'a 10 fois moins que c'est ce
qu au deuxième tour des municipales
c'est moins que le nombre de
fonctionnaires à paris on y reviendra
dans un instant le destin d'anne hidalgo
à paris je voudrais
qu'on avance d'abord sur la question du
parti elle l est républicain
raclée également pour le parti et les à
moins de 5% pour valérie pécresse qui a
rêvé ce matin s'être endettés
personnellement les coûte 7 millions de
remboursement manquent pour boucler le
budget de la campagne
les républicains ne peuvent pas faire
face à ses dépenses
je chili endettés personnellement à
hauteur de 5 millions d'euros
c'est pour cela que je lance ce matin un
appel national aux dons non à tout ce
qu'ils m'ont apporté leur suffrage mais
aussi à tous ceux qui ont préféré hier
le vote utile et enfin à tous les
français qui sont attachés au pluralisme
politique et à la liberté d'expression
j'ai besoin de votre aide d'urgence
d'ici le 15 mai pour boucler le
financement de cette campagne
présidentielle voilà l'appel lancé par
valérie pécresse j'accueille steve
jourdain bonsoir si bienvenue reçoit au
plateau de sens public l'enjeu de ce
lundi chez l air s'était notamment de
savoir si une consigne de vote allait
être donnée à l'issue de ce premier tour
et le lendemain de soirée le thomas
quelle journée quelle journée chez les
as l'air a commencé très tôt cette
journée 10 heures rendez vous au siège
les républicains rue vaugirard à paris
première réunion c'était le comité
stratégique autour de valeurs et valérie
pécresse publier leur ont entonné avec
un bureau politique du parti bureau qui
comprend toute la direction du parti les
chapeaux à plumes comme on dit le bureau
a débuté à midi objectif bien c'était de
s'accorder sur la ligne à adopter pour
le second tour sur le papier c'était
vraiment pas évident finalement c'est la
ligne de christian jacob le patron du
parti qui l'a emporté on va l'écouter
notre famille politique a toujours été
il reste un adversaire déterminé du
rassemblement national
aucune voix ne peut se tu es sur marine
le pen son projet politique et
économique nous conduirait au chaos les
républicains ne sont ni fongible dans le
maquereau nisme ni dans le lepénisme il
existe une autre voie celle de la droite
républicaine qui doit exister par
elle-même pour éviter l' immobilisme le
laxisme et le recul de la france pendant
cinq ans aucune voix pour marine le pen
c'est une position qui laisse ouverte la
possibilité bien de ne pas voter
emmanuel macron elle donne la
possibilité de voter blanc par exemple
cette ligne a été adopté donc au bureau
politique des leurs dans une très très
large majorité un sur 130 voix exprimées
116 se sont portés sur la motion de
christian jacob il ya eu 13 abstentions
et un vote contre quand même le vote
compte c'est celui de guillaume larrivé
le député et l'air de l'yonne qui avait
appelé on s'en souvient peut-être avant
le premier tour à construire une
nouvelle majorité avec emmanuel macron
en prévision des législatives mais ça il
n'en est pour l'instant en tout cas pas
encore question pour l'ancien ministre
sarkozyste marc philippe daubresse
nous voulons rester indépendant et pas
nous fondre dans une sorte de parti
attrape-tout
united colors of the emmanuel macron non
voilà la journée s'est terminée en
beauté avec la réunion des groupes
parlementaires le groupe ait l'air à
l'assemblée nationale le web elle est
ici au sénat ambiance on imagine
évidemment très écrit ce secret est
crispé ce qu'on nous dit pour l'instant
c'est qu'il faut à tout prix maintenir
l'unité du groupe l air à tout prix
maintenir l'unité de la majorité
sénatoriale cet après-midi gérard
larcher a dit qu'il voterait à titre
personnel pour emmanuel macron mais qui
les laissait et bien les sénateurs
libres de leur choix pour le deuxième
tour merci steve jourdain bérengère bond
ça craque de tous les côtés est ce que l
air est mort elle est un mal en point et
l'est hermine et hélène rapide siège
loue des locaux qu'il faut bien financer
elle n'aura pas ses comptes de campagne
rembourser donc oui évidemment ça va mal
ils ont une centaine de députés sortants
il va falloir qu'ils qui sauve un peu
les meubles dans cet entre deux tours
pour éviter de pour limiter la classe on
va dire et pourtant tu est effectivement
de de sauver ce qu'ils peuvent deux
groupes
parlementaires parce que parce que c'est
là aussi que la survie va se jouer alors
quand on regarde les intentions de vote
c'est difficile de savoir ce que vont ce
que vont faire les électeurs de valérie
pécresse le monde et on est sur un peu
plus de 40% je crois qui est qui dans
les intentions de vote en tout cas
estime qu' état de forte chance
aujourd'hui de voter par emmanuel macron
donc oui c'est ça j'en ai vu dans votre
dernier baromètre ses 46% aussi ça
exactement
un tiers de l'abstentionnisme c'est ça
j'ajouterai juste et bernal plus de
lignes et l'eire n'a plus d'alliance et
des l'air n'a plus de chef puisqu'on
sait que christian jacquiau va remettre
son mandat en jeu vraisemblablement à la
rentrée prochaine en tout cas c'est ce
qu'il avait indiqué aujourd'hui aucune
figure de ne se détache quant à la ligne
n'ont pas tranché c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont dans cette situation là et aux
dialogues et aux alliances électorales
qui leur permettrait de conquérir le
poids on voit bien qu'ils n'en ont plus
et si on se projette de nouveau vers les
législatives frédéric potier il ya là il
ya la question nicolas sarkozy va bien
il va bien sortir de du chapeau à plumes
d'en parler steam jourdain l'instant
exactement c'est ce que j'avais ajouté
il ya un silence assourdissant qui est
celui de nicolas sarkozy est donc la
question est de savoir si président de
la république l'ancien présent la
république sortira de cette réserve à
l'occasion des législatives pour aller
peut-être soutenir des anciens proches
parce que christian jacob qui sera
probalement candidats aussi à sa
réélection à l'occasion de législatives
dont là vraiment ça sera un signal qui
sera très attendu et sur les quais sur
lequel je pense que les députés sortants
comme beaucoup mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
imaginer dans les alliances en prévision
des législatives jean daniel
les viscères une partie des députés
aujourd'hui et l'eire qui pourraient se
présenter sur une bannière majorité
présidentielle par exemple ah oui tout
est envisageable aujourd'hui il faudra
attendre le deuxième tour faudra
peut-être déjà attendre de voir comment
on va réfléchir la formation politique
de d'emmanuel macron quel sera son
optique est ce que serait une optique
hégémonique donc c'est à dire faire en
sorte qu'ils puissent avoir uniquement
une personne par deux ponts qui va être
étiqueté majorité présidentielle est ce
que ça peut être le cas plusieurs par
circonscription ça arrive parfois qu'on
laisse en fait une compétition
orchestrée de la part de différents
acteurs qui sont dans les coudes et de
circonstance pendant gagnable et qu'elle
va être également la position des
candidats aient l'air ça va jouer à ce
niveau là ça va jouer également à mon
avis en fonction du score et du résultat
du deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle parce que ça peut changer
fondamentalement la donne est également
de la capacité ou pas d'eric zemmour de
pouvoir présenter des candidats
localement ne sera pas forcément le cas
partout mais il ya certains endroits ont
tous pensé pour faire vite au sud est de
la france où il y aura également des
enjeux parti en question si journal a
annoncé gérard larcher donc à titre
personnel a dit qu'il voterait mails
macron al'inverse
sur retailleau a annoncé qu'il allait
s'abstenir bruno retailleau merci marie
de me souffler son prénom décidément on
est fatigué au lendemain d'une soirée
électorale le patron des sénateurs et
l'air ici un mode eric zemmour tient
matthieu croissandeau parce que
discours quand même un petit peu
crépusculaire moi ça m'a rappelé et
l'ambiance de son de son clip de le
lancement de campagne on aurait dit un
imprécateur des nombreuses dans son
appentis en train de haranguer ses
troupes dans j'exagère un peu eric
zemmour en fait il finit là où il a
commencé c'est-à-dire qu'il fait le
score qu'il avait en démarrant dans la
campagne autour de 2 7% il en vient à
appeler pour marine le pen dont il n'a
cessé de dire qu'elle n'avait aucune
chance de remporter la présidentielle
parce qu'elle était une incapable on
s'est quand même compliqué pour lui et
hier il a dit moi je ne suis pas un
politicien professionnel il a répété ce
mantra qui a fait sa campagne or son
avenir il n'y a pas d'avenir pour lui en
politique s'il ne devient pas un
politicien professionnel et donc son
discours était tendue lien entre cette
affirmation là et l'idée que reconquête
le parti allait perdurer que c'est
formidable qui a eu deux millions de
voix que j'ai déjà 120 adhérents et
qu'ils allaient se présenter avec la
bataille et les continuer législatives
s'il tombe là dedans dans cette danse
est ce métier de politique qui va perdre
sa spécificité qu'est ce qui reste mais
il reste les intuitions qu'on peut
contester d'un polémiste d'extrême
droite qui aura marqué la campagne qui
aura suscité une forme d' emballement
médiatique une forme de déco dans la
population aussi mais en tout cas ils
aventure personnelle qui se termine en
une très lourde défaite pour quelqu'un
qui s'est cru un moment aux portes du
second tour dans la mire une dimension
avec un intéressant c'est quand vous
interrogez les français sur leurs
motivations de vote où quasiment tous
les électorats met en avant la question
du pouvoir d'achat même l'électorat
d'emmanuel maintenant ce qui n'était pas
forcément le cas il ya encore quelques
semaines tous sauf un sauf l'électorat
d'eric zemmour en fête qui met cette
côté facettes dimensions plutôt de côté
et qui revient vraiment sur ce qu'on
voyait il ya de nombreuses années
concernant le ratio national ou front
national c'est-à-dire l'immigration et
la sécurité et on voit là peut-être le
point d'aboutissement d'une stratégie
qu'il a cherché à opérer c'est à dire
faire en sorte que cette thématique
devient la thématique centrale dans le
débat national et de manière à ce qu'il
puisse en être le réceptacle d'un point
de vue logique d'opinion puis de
comportement électoral et cette
stratégie en l'espèce a complètement
échoué on a pu voir d'ailleurs au cours
des 15 années jour si vous avez regardé
les comptes twitter ses prises de parole
et cetera que le moindre fait divers
entre guillemets été mis en avant de
cette scène de sa part le fait de parler
d'une forme de de france orange
mécanique pour faire monter cette
pression
mme allemand dans les motivations de
vote au final ça n'a pas eu de prise et
on est resté vraiment sur les
thématiques plus tôt à caractère social
qu'a caractères identité à cette
caricature un peu qu'ils ont eu prise et
donc c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles il a baissé fortement en
cette fin de campagne paradoxalement en
fait il a même d'une certaine façon
favoriser profiter à marine le pen dans
cette façon de
d'abord vous souvenez vous content quand
guillaume pelletier quand un certain
nombre de membres du et rennes sont
partis chez eric zemmour on a on a un
temps estimé que ça pouvait lui porter
préjudice qui a été en fait en réalité l
inverse si là il a purgé d'une certaine
façon toute cette partie plus radicale
plus libérale plus les identitaires de
du rassemblement national et ce qui a
favorisé ville évidemment cette
stratégie de dédiabolisation dont on a
beaucoup parlé mais je pense que marine
le pen n'a pas du tout à s'en plaindre
on en viendrait presque à se demander si
ça n'a pas été jusqu'à quel point ça
n'aurait pas été un peu arrangé parce
que franchement c'est c'était assez
efficace fallait potier on avait le
sentiment hier soir que kerrigan pour
parler à ses fidèles et uniquement à ses
fidèles vous avez ressenti ça va il faut
qu'il y avait une dimension presque
secteur quand même dans son propos avec
là aussi des choses
assez hallucinante quand eric zemmour
dit je suis parti de rien il est parti
d'une heure de télévision par jour quand
il dit nous allons traverser les
batailles les campagnes extra un
discours complètement
lyrique et qui parle effectivement je
pense à une frange le très radical et
très idéologisé de la droite de la
droite de l'extrême droite et au fond
c'est peut-être aussi une forme de
défaite du trump heist avec un style
très violent très agressif en permanence
notamment sur des sujets je pense à la
mémoire à au maréchal pétain la shoah
aux personnes lgbt il s'est peut-être
trompé d'époque voilà il a peut-être eu
des intuitions il a peut-être plus de 1
des relais très puissant mais moi je
pense qu'il s'est peut-être trompé
d'époque le report de voix évidemment
prudent tous ces reports de voix dont on
parle ce sont ces voix là des sondages
et ça peut évoluer dans l'est dans les
12 13 jours qui viennent il ya une
campagne de second tour qui va se
dérouler et qui peut faire bouger les
lignes mais le report de voix à
l'instant t des électeurs d'eric zemmour
c'est quoi c'est neuf sur dix presque
pratiquement 8 sur 10 et huit sur dix il
ya une forme de constance qui vont chez
marie losique il faut que marine le pen
qui ya une forme de constance en fait il
ya une fluidité assez importante de
l'électorat d'eric zemmour vers
l'électro allemagne opel qui pour partie
d'ailleurs s'est produit hier dont on a
vu une partie de la société missionnaire
ce qui est intéressant c'est que dans
l'hypothèse où on l'avait testé à man où
eric zemmour aurait pu être au 2e jour
où marine le pen n'aura pas pu se
qualifier les vases communicants était
beaucoup moins fluide c'est à dire qu'en
fait ça a fonctionné dans la sens mais
pas dans l'autre est en fait la
thématique immigration qui pour partie
faisait partie du corpus de marine le
pen et est intégrable de la part des
progrès moore en revanche le fait que
lui-même n'est pas une dimension à
caractère social ou de discours sur la
réplique le lite est préjudiciable dans
l'autre sens allez on va terminer ce
premier débat de sens public avec le
destin politique d'anne hidalgo la
candidate socialiste essayer malgré tout
hier soir de se projeter dans l'avenir
je continuerai à mettre toute mon
énergie de femmes politiques et de
citoyenne pour une france républicaine
plus fort
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que potillon live ou qui tout
à l'heure je redonne le chiffre pour
ceux qui nous rejoignent à l'instant à
hidalgo a réuni sur son nom au moins de
23 mille électeurs parisiens sur un
million de votants de 17% de parisiens
qui ont voté pour leurs mères jeu son
pouvoir municipal
va forcément ressortir fragilisé d'un
d'une présidentielle aussi calamiteuse
c'est pas possible autrement oui la
catastrophe absolue pour le parti
socialiste pour sa candidate et
catastrophes assez homogène d'ailleurs
puisque anne hidalgo fait 3 % dans les
landes a fait au maximum 3 8% en corrèze
dans des fiefs socialistes très institué
est donc l'enjeu ça va être mon avis pas
seulement la ville de paris mais ça va
être tout le reste est la question de la
disparition complète du parti socialiste
dont la vie est posée ce soir mais sur
le destin de dargaud matthieu
croissandeau
faut aussi
aussi c'est sa majorité voilà sa
majorité va-t-elle va-t-elle tenir à ce
qui ce qui est sûr c'est qu'au conseil
de paris sont l'opposition ne lui fera
aucun cadeau elle elle sort de cette
campagne très abîmée traite
décrédibiliser parce qu'au delà de la
faiblesse du ps et au delà du grand
mouvement tectonique entamé en 2017 qui
fait que le parti socialiste comme l air
sont sont touchés par cette compagnie
cette recomposition du paysage elle a
commis des erreurs personnelles elle a
donné le sentiment d'une sincérité à
vouloir dire qu'elle ne voulait pas de
candidat tu peux être candidate qu'elle
voulait pas de primaire puis vouloir une
primaire donner le sentiment de
quelqu'un qui ne savait pas au fond de
décider qui ne savaient pas tranché
qu'ils étaient capables de changer
d'avis au jour le jour au gré de son
intérêt puis ensuite c'est ce qui est
une idée qui est imprimé sks cas quelque
chose qui est sorti qu'on retient de la
campagne d'anne hidalgo rien les gens
ont entendu des mots ils ont entendu
parler mais ils n'ont pas entendu
d'idées ils ont pas entendu de vision et
donc pour le coup il reste encore toute
une partie de son mandat vert puisque l
on va ça va continuer et elle mon avis
être c'est vrai dans de grandes
difficultés
où sont passés les électeurs socialistes
ils sont restés pour une bonne partie
chez eux et puis ils ont voté également
très nettement en faveur de jean-luc
mélenchon quand vous prenez
la différence à la presse aip ce qu'on
appelle les électeurs socialistes parce
qu'on fait est la base de référence est
elle celle de benoît hamon 6% à la
dernière élection présidentielle 2% en
fait ça veut dire qu'il ya que 4 points
entre guillemets récupérer c'est chose
presque à réaliser jean luc mélenchon
donc c c'est un électorat qui quoi qu'il
en soit qui est déstabilisée et qui pose
une question comment la gauche peut-elle
être aux responsabilités demain et que
cette question là n'a pas ni
véritablement été abordé par ma part à
lego universe et man obtenu une réponse
aux yeux des électeurs il ya comme un
enjeu qui est un enjeu de du bilan qui
peut être fait de ce qui a été effectué
au cours de la période 2012 2017 avec
des électeurs de gauche qui ont du mal à
pouvoir trouver des éléments de fierté
d'avoir porter françois hollande à
l'elysée est pas forcément une mesure
emblématique où une politique ou manière
de faire de la politique il permettre de
dire au moins la gauche au pouvoir c'est
ça et c'est ce qui a eu une incidence
extrêmement importantes en dehors de sa
campagne donne elle-même sur le score
qu'a connu agnel gruyère merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce premier débat je rappelle le titre
de votre livre le sioux portrait
d'edouard philippe qui est publié aux
éditions de l'archipel